uh  get ready for the next battle  hello  [Music]  so  wins  and the director of the super smash bros  ultimate game  kazuya mishima from the fighting game  series tekken will join the battle  surprise i'll go over the details at a  later date  so please sit tight for today though  we've prepared a short video to showcase  kazia's moves in super smash brothers  ultimate  please take a look  uh  oh  this feels like tekken no it's super  smash brothers ultimate  i'll talk about the fighter more in a  future presentation  we still have to record it first  actually  the air date is shown below please stay  tuned  thank you mr sakurai  new fighter kazia will join the fight in  super smash brothers ultimate  please look forward to seeing how kazia  who has experienced many harsh battles  across the tekken series will fight in  this game  alright let's continue with our first  batch  of nintendo switch headlines